if you always work together with the
same partner with the same one or two
project leads for an extended period of
time and then your next evaluation
session is up but think about it what
will be more strong to make your case to
be a high performer to be a rockstar to
potentially get that fast track
promotion will it be stronger if only
one person one partner cheers for you
and tries to make the case for you or
will it be stronger if several Partners
several senior employees of the company
will make the case for you you want to
make sure that you have a broad exposure
then there's a certain set of people who
can all say positive things about you